Film Courage: What would you tell a 20-year-old
filmmaker on the realities of making a living
as a filmmaker?
Gavin Michael Booth, Writer/Director/Cinematographer:
It’s funny because they just started a podcast
with the same idea which is the phrase Here
is my advice, not that you’ll take it.
Listen to the people giving you advice first
off because you think that what they’re
going to tell you is honest advice, it’s
harsh, it’s not going to be easy, it’s
going to require a lot more money, patience
and heartache than you think you can bear
and you’re going to say “They just sound
jaded because they’ve been around a long
time.
There must be a faster, cheaper, easier way
to get this done?”
And then you’ll fumble in the dark for a
long time to eventually turn around and say
“Oh?
That advice they gave me, I should have taken
it.”
So listen to your elders!
You hit a certain point where you start saying
that to people and say “Oh!
That’s exactly what my parents said to me.”
But the best thing is just take advice, take
the time to learn, don’t ever think that
you’re above something.
If you want to be a director, great!
Go grip on some people’s films and understand
and watch other directors work.
Understand how important every role on that
set is so that you never talk down or take
anyone for granted that’s on the set and
just keep making stuff.
Even if you’re not proud of the short you
made, put it up online anyways.
It’s part of learning to take criticism.
It’s part of learning to fail.
Keep making stuff and understand that it’s
the longest relationship you’ll ever have
because you will fall in and out of love with
it along the way but it doesn’t mean you
should ever give up or not give it a second
chance or not find a way to make amends, kiss
and make up with yourself and your creative
dreams and don’t ever think that a major
setback means it’s over because you’re
going to have a lot of them and most of us
do.
Not all of us are lucky enough to get plucked
out of film school on our first film and have
a star track record right to their lifetime
achievement award at the end of their career.
It’s a lot of misery.
I always say it’s 99 setbacks for every
one thing that works out.
So when that hundredth thing works out it
has to fill you with so much excitement and
joy and courage and then wanting to go and
make the next thing that it will shield you
from the next 99 disappointments, so when
you get the next one, you got to do the same
thing.
So that’s the reality of it.
It’s going to sting for a long time.
But you’ve got to just enjoy what you’re
doing along the way and learn to not be end-career
focused because you never know how it’s
going to come about but you try to fixate
on it has to be this, this and this, rarely
life is that.
So you have to be able to say it’s going
to be this but I might have to take this sideways
trip.
It looks like one of these INDIANA JONES maps
at the beginning or JAMES BOND to go from
country to country.
They want to go from here to here.
Sometimes that means Sallah has got to take
them all over here to take them back to that
arc.